a 617 830 for 750 is the number we will
take a couple more calls who's up next
with us hey david this is andres Tino
from Baltimore Maryland what can we do
for you David I gotta tell you I'm a big
fan of your show I think you do a
brilliant job analyzing the daily
physical news thank you and I find it a
useful tool so truly I thank you and I
think Luis preferred over the time never
listening and uh I'm really chatted to
hear that lewisham leaving you're
excited explain that in what way
although forgive me I'm saddened I'm
saddened all I mr. not Lulu if we can
turn my headphone up just a tiny bit I
don't want to miss a word of azure
saddened I thought you said you were
excited for a second now I can't imagine
anybody being excited by Luis leaving
and uh I I'm actually a little jealous
of the idea that Louis has this ability
to just decide to pick up and leave
because he's a happy with the area then
i find myself actually I'm from West
Palm Beach Florida yeah recently moved
to Baltimore and I move for work because
it was a better opportunity yeah here
Louis thinking and now I'm just gonna go
try the city because i feel like it end
up whatever happens happens well listen
a lot of people are reacting to the news
in the same way you are which is both
confusion and jealousy as to how Louis
has just decided that uh hey he's
looking for warmer weather he's looking
for land he's looking for acreage and
growing his own food and who knows what
else and that's gonna be his priority
well that's it it's a it's well first of
all thank you and I I'm uh back thank
you for listening and and not calling me
an idiot uh which many people like to do
I have this like I don't know maybe we
can call the Louis happiness index and
uh it's just on you know I've I've
weighed everything and I just don't
think I can be happy here and so I have
to find some place where where I can be
happy it because that is what is most
important to me and and if I'm not
making as much money as I would like um
I
like to think that uh your parents will
bail you out now no I'd like that I'd
like to think that I can still be happy
so op it's an experiment really we say
with peace and love that Lewis is doing
what he needs to do for the best lowest
possible and who can be angry about that
right absolutely I agree that the ascii
value not getting the better of you you
feel call about do tradition or you stay
up at night a bit worrying about how
this transition will take wait you know
all of a sudden I'm very having a very
hard time here as well my transitionals
ID about matters i think dave was
probably has probably more anxiety about
my transition than I do um because of
course now we have new people here and
and uh people have to learn the process
and it's uh it's I've been here for so
long it's it's just second nature and so
my transition luckily is going to be
quite smooth is going to be quite smooth
as can be pretty easy because my moving
is going to be no problem I don't even
have my own furniture here I don't do
with any of that it's a short move it's
a short distance and and my parents are
nice enough to to put me up uh
temporarily so that I don't have to
scramble to find any place to live or
anything like that and how temporary
will that be their hospitality do you
predict uh well to be determined ok all
right on that note thank you so much for
the call we we do have to run
unfortunately you are the last caller
today and I hope you'll keep calling and
even after even in spite of your sadness
about Lewis leaving I hope you'll call
in again opaque is a big thing I
appreciate that day thank you and Louis
I wish you the best of luck i'm so glad
i got on to tell you that personally
thank you so much all right and on that
note we will take a break we still have
a huge show coming up and I don't know
was it just me Louis or did something
very strange happened to that callers
phone line towards the end oh well it's
his phone cell phones okay digital noise
stuff yeah alright we'll take a break
back after this